I did a podcast with Bobby Lee and he
said he was extremely kind and he said
that he was scared shitless
um to be on on the podcast and he
actually literally took he asked as the
first thing to go and take a dump
because of how scared he was uh so that
leads me to a question what's the
scariest thing you've ever done
or maybe what's the scariest you've ever
been before performance
I mean I always get a little nervous I
think you're doing it right if you're
still nervous you know are you nervous
today
well no man because this isn't a
performance I'm being completely genuine
yeah you're wearing a suit yeah that was
I feel like that makes you nervous where
it makes me nervous listen I hate
wearing a [ __ ] collar if you're
watching this on YouTube you can see me
just this is yeah I'm constantly doing
it's like I'm doing like a cheap Rodney
Dangerfield but I am truly when you move
your head it kind of makes it seem like
you're like a mobster who's pissed off a
little bit like you [ __ ] crossed me
one last time you suck you know yeah
it's mutt yeah I think it's the first
time I dug a hole [ __ ] hole Jesus
um no but truly I hate having a a caller
I should I can't wait to just wear
pajamas in that [ __ ] uh cabin or
nothing at all walk around Bobby Lee
style yeah um this most scared I've been
before a performance
I can't pinpoint I can't pinpoint
anything I I
you know when I was a kid right I like I
said I was fortunate enough to start
acting as a team and stuff uh
professionally and I just remember my
first gig and I remember saying my
handful of lines in the bathroom mirror
the night before going
this might be my only [ __ ] shot
you're not gonna get me I'm gonna be
solid
and I I when I'm if I'm worried about
something I will rehearse it and
rehearse it and rehearse it as an actor
until it's impossible for me not to get
a take at least that I'm 100 if not 95
maybe percent happy with and the rest
for me is Letting Go which is hard
because I can be a real
perfectionist I always want another I
always want to do it a little better
that's what's great about podcasting is
one take and you're done there's no
takes
um you're just talking and it's over and
you're doing some silly stuff and I'll
I'll you know can you say that part
again about why podcasting is great
podcasting is great yeah because it's
one take and it's over it's just it's it
what I said it again ah [ __ ]
um I see what you did uh and I'd yeah I
fell right for it but um I'm playing
checkers and you're playing chess that's
your problem
you know but still when we do the
podcast we'll like finish and I'll look
over at Chattanooga that one thing that
I did wasn't that fun he's like shut up
man just yeah it doesn't matter it's a
[ __ ] hang we're just we're hanging
with our friends out there that's what
we're doing so that anxiety is there the
self-criticism or whatever that is that
voice I say sorry after takes I'll I'll
always finish a take and go and I've had
director to the detriment of myself yeah
I've had directors be like stop doing
that yeah because I'll like finish
taking then I also have like the the
will face so I'm just like I'll finish
it and cut
and I'm making a face right now like I
smelled something but that's what I'll
do I'll literally be like ah because I
just
I I I look at
I look at what I do in the pure sense as
I think I think a lot of people want to
be good at something I've only the only
thing I've ever really wanted to be good
at is being an actor and that's that's
the only thing of course I want to be a
good person I want to be a good partner
to my fiance I want to have kids and be
a the father that I had and and want to
be the parent that I had from my parents
who were [ __ ] amazing wonderful
people and uh there's all those things
that's all that's all you know you
should want all those things but as far
as doing a thing like what is my what is
my trade you know I want to be
really good at it my my um my parents
grew up in Napoli in Italy right and I
say Napoli because I'm Italian and so my
grandfather and my mom's side my Nono
Pepe he was a plumber and he was also uh
he was also like a handyman yeah like
people would bring him like you know
like the old Chianti bottle with like
with the woven bottom part like people
would bring him like a broken bottle be
like hey you know Joseph can you fix
this and he'd be saying like you're
telling the backstory of Mario that's
not actually your family life yeah but
okay yeah well thanks yeah and so just
that be what he would fix a bottle and
give it back someone and he was a he was
a really good plumber my mom used to
always say that guy was an amazing he
was a great he took pride in that yeah I
always feel like you know
there's what you set out to do as an
idealistic little teenager I want to be
like so and so and I want to you know
hear my Big Dreams and stuff and I can't
believe that I'm still in the business
okay that's first of all let me say that
right now I can't I do I can't believe
it but what I've re what I really
I I it's the one thing that it's like I
can't give up on a take you know I need
it to be as good as I can possibly get
it and I don't really know why that is
outside of wanting to be good at
something when you open the Yellow Pages
if I'm a plumber I'm not you know I I'm
not Roto-Rooter like I'm not the guy
with the big full page ad but I'm also
not
you know Triple A Abacus brothers or
whatever like the shitty one yeah I I
would like to Hope
that just and I'm saying this with with
pride for what I do I'm not trying to
say here's my standing or where I want
to be in the [ __ ] business that's not
what I mean I mean that I want to be
good at it you know we all hello
Friedman Enterprises
that's the hotel phone
hello
you have some fruit
some sliced fruit no do you want some
sliced fruit I'm all good no we're good
thank you so much
all right all right bye-bye it's always
a fruit plate
everyone's always trying to hand you a
fruit plate in life you know
if that was actually like the CIA and
they were actually saying something else
and this is I'm just saying fake stuff
about you want some fruit yeah I want
some fruit then all of a sudden there's
the Red Dot on my head and yeah and the
ceiling disappears and the the ca was
like wrap it up wrap it up wrap it wrap
it up you jump out the window and
there's a helicopter waiting uh what
were we talking about uh food
distracting me so oh the do you want to
be that's one of the yellow page ad I
want to be the guy on the second or
third page yeah where it's like you're
not gonna you know you're not gonna pay
what that guy charges you but we're not
gonna I'm not gonna charge you with this
loser chart you know I want to break
down the middle and the work is
guaranteed that's kind of what I want to
you know it's the one thing that I that
I've been fortunate enough to be doing
my whole life and that I want to uh
that I want to be good at you know
everyone wants to be good at something
if you're fortunate enough to be able to
do what you love is a job I mean my God
I'm so I'm I again I can't believe I get
to do it I just want to be good at it so
that I can [ __ ] you know die someday
and go uh
I tried not to give up on a take and I
you know and I will rehearse it still in
the in the bathroom mirror the night
before if I have to
yeah but I still I have that soft
critical voice I just
uh after every part after this podcast
I'll probably be like you you're boring
why are you so boring
and I just gave a lecture at MIT I was
like
I'm I got so much love from people
there's such beautiful people and I just
remember walking home
just feeling like we like I wasted
everybody's time you know and then it's
it's I don't know what that is I don't
you know I I do hope that that's a voice
that won't destroy me you know like
that's really human of you to admit that
because people don't wanna
they wouldn't assume that of course from
you or anything that I mean you've got
A A large group of students in there
listening to you and feeling the way and
thinking what they think of you uh so
that's really interesting to hear you
um admit that but it's also I would
expect nothing else you have to be able
to it's such a I mean you're a human
[ __ ] being and I'm trying to figure
out if that you know for some people
that might hear that that would say well
that's a problem you have to fix and I
think that that might be just who I am
yeah because I'm not you know I've been
very very fortunate not to have chemical
you know like the depression where I get
into a dark place like it gets stuck in
the in a downward spiral it's it's
usually a thing that lasts you write it
out and you and then after a good
night's sleep you're back to uh back to
your happy self so I think
I have to try to figure that that out is
that just part of the creative process
being a creative human in this world I
haven't found any other way I'm always
kicking myself take that Duty you can't
you can't the the you're not gonna be
human until you feel some despair yeah
criticism absolutely hate the [ __ ] that
you're doing sometimes